cette vidéo est sponsorisé par north vpn
comme vous le savez le marvel
cinématiques universe avance constamment
beaucoup de productions sorte et cela
peut être par moment compliqué de rester
à jour heureusement il existe désormais
les plateformes vod qui permettent de
voir ou revoir les films depuis chez
vous et c'est là que norme vpn
intervient effectivement pour le moment
en france nous n'avons pas toujours
accès à tout ce qui sort en vod il faut
attendre un moment avant d'avoir accès à
certaines productions et nord européenne
peut vous aider à y accéder grâce à
noordpeene en un seul clic vous pouvez
changer votre localisation pour
n'importe quel pays pour accéder à du
contenu qui n'est pas disponible en
france vous pourrez avoir accès à des
films comme chan chee ou encore eternalz
par exemple c'est un outil que j'utilise
au quotidien et je sais que cela me
servira pour les sorties vod de doctor
strange 2 thor cat ou encore black
panther 2 qui sortent cette année
d'ailleurs n'oubliez pas que nos bpn est
accessible via six appareils différents
et surtout ses six appareils seront
sécurisés et protégés face aux criminels
et à la surveillance également grâce à
ses cinq mille 200 serveurs répartis
dans 60 pays noordpeene possède une très
bonne vitesse d'exécution si vous êtes
intéressé n'hésitez pas à accéder au
lien disponible en descriptions norvez
pn vous propose une offre inédite de
deux ans d'abonnement avec une réduction
de plus de 70% et un mois offerts
satisfait ou remboursé sur 30 jours
merci beaucoup à nord de pn pour leur
confiance que la vidéo commence bonjour
à toutes et à tous et bienvenue dans
cette nouvelle vidéo encore une fois
dédié à doctor strange 2 multiverse of
madness mais cette fois ci c'est un cas
un petit peu particulier puisque on va
se concentrer sur le cas du rwanda qui
est pour moi le plus gros point
d'interrogation du film énormément de
choses ont été dites sur son cas comme
quoi elle serait la méchante du film il
ya eu délit qui ont circulé bref je vous
propose aujourd'hui de faire le point
d'essayer de soulever et pourquoi pas
résoudre certains mystères et puis bah
surtout pourquoi pas émettre quelques
petites théorie car franchement le cas
du rwanda il est vraiment passionnant et
surtout on s'est très clairement qu'elle
va envoyer du lourd dans le film
d'ailleurs j'en profite pour le cal est
comme ça mais n'hésitez pas à vous
abonner si le contenu vous plaît on se
rapproche de plus en plus des 100 mille
abonnés donc voilà un énorme merci pour
votre soutien ne tardons pas comment son
la vidéo premièrement je pense qu'il
faut que nous fassions une sorte de
petite remise de contexte de la
situation actuelle de rwanda car cela va
nous permettre de mieux comprendre dans
quel état il se trouve pour affronter
les événement de doctor strange de
luanda est très clairement l'héroïne du
mc u qui est le plus souffert son
enfance a été chaotique son passage dans
id ranelagh clairement pas aider à
s'épanouir pietro est mort dans avengers
deux visions dans infinity ward puis la
série one ta vision a été le coup de
grâce luanda a refermé l'ex ce qui
signifie qu'elle a perdu ses enfants le
fait que huit jeunes aussi et même si le
véritable vision a été reconstruit il
n'est plus celui qu'il était auparavant
en plus de ça c'est important de le
souligner avec les avait demandé une
game le qg des avengers a été détruit le
groupe est plus ou moins 10 ou notamment
du fait que tony est mort et steve pris
sa retraite donc elle n'a plus vraiment
aux d'appui et surtout c'est très
important de le rappeler mais avec les
événements de one la vision même si
monica rambo jimmy ou encore darcis
soutenait rwanda cette dernière a quand
même retenu en otage une ville entière
en faisant souffrir inconsciemment ses
habitants donc clairement rwanda est en
quelque sorte en cavale et seul ce n'est
pas anodin si elle se retrouve dans une
petite maison à la campagne très loin de
tout bon je vous le répète à chaque fois
mais pour moi et d aegon d'accord mais
voilà ça c'est qu'un détail bref vous
vous demande très certainement où je
veux en venir avec tout ça et bien la
raison est très simple wendat n'a plus
rien elle est isolée est complètement
seul et c'est là que cela peut devenir
clairement intéressant si vous vous
rappelez bien de la scène post générique
de word aviv ron huldaï clermont train
d'essayer d'apprendre et comprendre son
pouvoir son rôle de scarlet witch et
petit teasing elle entend même le cri de
ses enfants en train de l'appeler au
secours c'est déjà un premier indice
intéressant car effectivement que le cri
de ses enfants soit véritable ou non ils
ne font pas partie du monde dans lequel
l'histoire du mcs se déroule ils ne font
pas partie de la réalité donc que le
crid à l'aide soit fake ou pas c'est
déjà un teasing pour nous faire
comprendre que wendat va commencer à
s'intéresser aux multivers et autre
dimension dans le but qu'elle tente de
retrouver ses enfants et par rapport à
ce que je vous disais un peu plus tôt
plus rien ne retient wendat dans cette
réalité elle est désormais la scarlet
witch un être capable de déformer la
réalité et maîtrisant la magie du chaos
est en possession du dard gold donc en
soi le multivers est une aubaine pour
elle pour aller voir ailleurs
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
maintenant il faut que nous relions ceci
a doctor strange et c'est là que la
véritable théorie commence dans chaque
film du marvel cinématiques universe le
vilain principal est toujours plus ou
moins facilement devinable par exemple
c'est idiot un mes torts 4 love and
thunder on n'a aucun teaser aucun
trailer on a très peu d'infos sur le
film encore pour le moment et pourtant
on connaît déjà l'antagoniste principal
ce sera gore le boucher des dieux alors
qu'ici dans doctor strange 2 avec
plusieurs teasing des tipis spot de
trailer on reste toujours énormément
dans le flou nous faisons face qu'à des
personnages plutôt gris ils peuvent pour
beaucoup être des antagonistes mais ils
peuvent aussi ne pas l'être du tout et
c'est quelque chose qui n'est pas anodin
et je dirais même que ce choix révèle
qu'il ya quelque chose de possiblement
plus profond une sorte de secret comme
si en fait il y avait une sorte de
mastermind une sorte de ville un cachet
un maître du jeu avec un plan en
exécution et wendat serait possiblement
la pièce maîtresse de tout ça je
m'explique kevin figuil a toujours des
na'vi jeunes spider man noir homes et dr
strange deux forment une sorte de
trilogie moins de vision nous a permis
de faire avancer l'histoire du rwanda
est la faire évoluer en scarlet witch et
spider man on wire homme est le premier
pas vers l'ouverture de notre réalité
avec le multivers et ça c'est un point
très intéressant car effectivement c'est
la première phrase du trailer de doctor
strange 2 qui nous le dit strange ne
doit pas lancer ce sortilège huang nous
l'affirment plus tard le sortilège de
strange qui l'a lancé dans spider man
ray home a ouvert la porte vers le
multivers est désormais n'importe qui ou
n'importe quoi peut arriver et menacer
la réalité c'est d'ailleurs probablement
à cause de ce sortilège qu'america
chavez est apparu dans notre réalité
tout comme la créature ressemblant à
shuma-gorath hausse lachgar cantos mais
pas que c'est aussi l'arrivée des
cauchemars de notre docteur strange je
vous renvoie vers ma vidéo concernant si
mr stranger pour en savoir plus mais il
s'agit clairement pour moi de nightmare
l'ouverture de la réalité avec le
multivers à cause du sortilège a
probablement permis aux sinister strange
plutôt nightmare de s'immiscer dans les
rêves de notre docteur strange et le
truc c'est que nightmare est un très
grand manipulateur il influence et
contrôler les gens dans leur sommeil
sans oublier que dans sa dimension des
rêves il possède les pleins pouvoirs
c'est un monde qui lui appartient il
petit faire tout et n'importe quoi donc
voilà si nightmare cherche à rentrer en
contact avec notre docteur strange c'est
qu'il ya une raison derrière est pire
que ça steven n'est peut-être pas la
seule cible de nightmare il pourrait
également s'intéresser à wendat et là il
faut que nous parlions des illuminati
tous
si nous suivons la trilogie tout monte
crescendo luanda est devenue la scarlet
witch nos héros m'a ouvert la porte vers
le multivers donc désormais nous allons
complètement plongé dans ce multi vert
de la folie sauf que cela ne va pas être
si simple que ça et le trailer nous l'a
prouvé strange est à dacca chavez se
font attraper par les illuminati ils
sont enfermés dans leur qg strange est
menotté est mort dos le condamne pour sa
profanation de la réalité bref nos
comprenant vite quel est le rôle des
illuminati dans le film ils semblent
agir comme des sortes de gardiens des
sortes de modérateur des héros qui
surveille s'il ne se passe pas trop de
dinguerie et cetera et cetera d'ailleurs
je le rajoute comme ça pour le fun car
c'est une idée qui me plaît beaucoup
mais je me demande si le suprême strange
dont nous avons vu la statue ne serait
pas le fondateur du groupe bref je le
call comme ça vous en faites ce que vous
voulez mais du coup ce que je voulais
dire par rapport au fait que les
illuminati sont comme des policiers
entre guillemets des réalités enfin bon
le mot est un peu fort mais vous
comprenez l'idée cela signifie qu'ils
doivent être en alerte concernant
plusieurs menaces multi vercel et que
peut être même qu'ils sont les gardiens
de certaines dimensions ou des entités
supra cosmique capable de tout anéantir
sont scellées et c'est ça qui est
pertinent car vous le savez tous deux
par les traileurs rwanda va mettre un
sacré bazar dans le qg des illuminati et
il y a de très fortes chances qu'elle
tue même plusieurs membres du groupe
après tout wendat désormais la plus
puissante des héroïnes du mc eu on parle
quand même de la scarlet witch capable
de prêts destinés l'anéantissement de
l'univers d'après le dark auld est
capable de manipuler la réalité comme
elle le souhaite et du coup en récemment
les illuminatis libéré de potentiel
gigantesque menaces qui pourraient tout
anéantir si nous essayons de recoller
les éléments du puzzle rwanda n'a plus
rien elle entend l'appel à l'aide de ses
enfants peut-être que c'est une
manipulation de nightmare pour la faire
s'intéresser aux multivers après tout
nightmare rentrer en contact avec
notre docteur strange pour se rapprocher
du rwanda et la manipuler du genre
pourquoi pas lui faire miroiter l'idée
qu'elle peut retrouver ses enfants dans
une autre réalité vu qu'elle serait la
seule à pouvoir affronter le groupe des
illuminati car elle est la scarlet witch
la seule entité capable de surpasser
même des sorciers suprême eh bien elle
serait poussé à les affronter comme ça
derrière cela libère une entité multi
vers celle du style un véritable show
magot race ou pourquoi pas un clown bon
c'est très décousue mais j'espère que
vous comprenez l'idée en tout cas ce qui
est pertinent c'est que déjà dans les
comics nightmare à travailler pour
chaumât gauras ici ils serviraient
d'avatar du mal pour en quelque sorte de
ramener son maître d'ailleurs j'aimerais
faire un court point là dessus mais
clairement cet ennemi n'est pour moi
qu'une créature multi vers celles
résultant du sort de strange qui a
ouvert la réalité au multivers même s'il
y a des possibles problèmes de droit
chez marvel concernant shuma-gorath il
est certain que marvel trouvera une
solution pour pallier à ça peut-être
qu'au final ils se serviront doc tonnes
tout reste possible ensuite pour moi il
ya des plans qui ne sont pas à ignorer
déjà nous avons un plan de wendat dans
la dimension miroir ce qui signifie
qu'elle va affronter notre docteur
strange donc rwanda va clairement pété
les plombs et il y a de grandes chances
que le dard cold ils soient également
pour quelque chose au vu du bout de ses
doigts qui sont devenus noirs signifiant
qu'elle peut être corrompue par le livre
de plus nous la voyons faire une sorte
de rituel comme si elle cherchait à
invoquer quelqu'un ou quelque chose ou
en date étant la scarlet witch nous
savons très peu de choses concernant ce
titre dans le mc eu mais par rapport aux
comics c'est une condition qui la relie
avec les grands anciens et plus
particulièrement tonnes le créateur du
dard gold wendat pourrait donc être un
réceptacle permettant de ramener une
entité multi vers celles liées à la
magie du chaos ce qui serait d'ailleurs
ironique c'est que doctor strange se
fasse juger par les illuminati pour ses
actions dans spider man aux ehome alors
qu'en réalité là les tables profanation
de la réalité était en fait réalisé par
rwanda enfin pour moi c'est quelque
chose dont je souhaitais vous parlait
depuis un moment mais je suis sûr et
certain qu'avec rwanda et charles xavier
ils vont nous sortir une grosse
référence à x men l'affrontement final
en vrai il y a de grandes chances que
charles meurt dans doctor strange eux
surtout si windham et le qg des
illuminati à feu et à sang charles
semble être un peu le leader du groupe
donc voilà on retrouve la thématique de
tweets chef pour désunir le groupe mais
bon je ne sais pas pour vous mais wendat
partagent beaucoup je trouve avec jean
grey on retrouve clairement ce côté
héroïne qui possède un pouvoir beaucoup
trop puissant et si wendat se mesure au
professeur x cela va clairement nous
donner un remake du décès de charles
dans x men
d'ailleurs on n'en a pas parlé alors que
pourtant je voulais mentionner plusieurs
fois mais je souhaite de tout coeur que
nous ayons la présence d'un magnéto dans
doctor strange 2 les fans de comics vous
le savez très bien magnéto et le père de
wendat bon ce n'est pas le cas dans le
mc eu mais vu qu'on à charles xavier
imaginez si magnéto rencontré wendat
dans doctor strange days c'est une
référence que j'adorerais voir et wendat
retrouverez pourquoi pas une sorte de
figure paternelle elle qui est désormais
seul et sans famille mais bon magnéto
reste magnéto c'est un grand
manipulateur
donc voilà en revanche il y a un
problème que nous n'avons pas répondu
c'est qu'il est sûr qu'il y aura
plusieurs rwanda dans le film au moins
deux bon c'est pas tout à fait sûr mais
quand même dr strange 2 est clairement
un film parfait pour nous proposer de
nombreuses variantes des personnages que
nous connaissons rien que notre docteur
strange nous savons qu'il va rencontrer
au moins trois autres lui-même même
christine palmer qui est plutôt
secondaire aura une variante d'elle-même
donc voilà mais surtout ce qui me
perturbe énormément c'est ce fameux
premier poster du film on en avait parlé
dans la vidéo dédié au sinister strange
mais dessus nous retrouvons plusieurs
variants il y a le docteur strange que
nous connaissons il y a le defender
strange et il ya le sinister strange
sauf qu'il ya également de luanda ce qui
sous-entend clairement qu'il est censé y
avoir au moins deux honda dans le film
possiblement dans la construction du
poster au centre nous retrouvons
effectivement notre docteur strange mais
à sa gauche nous retrouvons le defender
strange qui nous avons normalement
d'après les comics est un variant plutôt
bienveillant accompagné d'une luanda qui
semble tout à fait normal alors qu'à
droite nous retrouvons un peu l'idée que
je vous partage depuis tout à l'heure
nous retrouvons le sinistre strange qui
est possiblement malveillants et
bizarrement juste à côté nous retrouvons
une luanda aux yeux jaunes comme si
elles étaient menaçantes c'est là tout
le dilemme il est clair que wendat ou du
moins une luanda sera une antagonistes
du film mais se pourrait-il qu'il y ait
une bonne luanda pour la contrer après
tout qui de mieux qu'une scarlet witch
pour contrer une autre scarlet witch
mais bon là j'avoue qu'on part vraiment
dans de la spéculation un petit peu
folle
enfin voila je pense qu'on a soulevé pas
mal de choses les mystères sont
clairement nombreux et bien évidemment
il faudra attendre le film pour enfin
avoir les réponses n'oubliez pas que ce
ne sont que des théories on est avant
tout là pour s'amuser à imaginer
et même en quelque sorte rêver quelque
part j'espère en tout cas sincèrement
que la vidéo vous aura plu j'ai pris
beaucoup de plaisir à la faire en
compagnie de mont brouilly rousseff
évidemment qui d'ailleurs lui aussi va
vous sortir une vidéo dédiée à luanda et
où j'apparaîtrai dedans donc voilà
n'hésitez pas à aller la voir n'hésitez
pas non plus à vous abonner si les
vidéos vous plaisent c'est très
important vous pouvez également me
suivre sur instagram ou twitter où je
suis plutôt actif et comme je vous
disais un peu plus tôt je vous conseille
vraiment cette vidéo dédiée aux sinister
strange car ce dernier cache vraiment
énormément de choses il ya vraiment
beaucoup de mystère derrière lui donc je
suis sûr que cela va vous intéresser je
compte sur vous pour laisser votre
meilleur pouces bleu et un commentaire
sur ce que vous avez pensé de la vidéo
ou de ouenza ou si vous avez des idées
concernant docteur strange 2 et puis bah
écoute et bah voilà c'était dargaud rock
que le lionheart soit avec vous allez
ciao tout le monde
[Musique]